dicton salle affiche du jour en avril ne
te découvre pas d'un fil en mai portent
la burqa qu'il te plaît
[Musique]
alors oui il ya une chose qu'il ya
claude bartolone qui a reçu des menaces
adressée au président de la douma de la
république socialiste soviétique
je tiens à dire que ce n'est pas de moi
même si je compte bien entendu porté
plainte pour plagiat
mariage gay toujours alors tu connais la
dernière blague de c'est un député qui
fait les marchés le dimanche et il dit
aux gens mais vous savez on fait
vraiment tout pour lutter contre le
chômage et tout électeur qui répond
occupez vous plutôt du mariage gay
[Applaudissements]
donc la france est le quatorzième pays
au monde à adopter le mariage gay ce qui
signifie quand même que deux son pays ne
l'ont pas adopté c'est colin on va enfin
pouvoir être de gauche et traiter le
tiers-monde d'arriérés
alors ça a conduit à l'expression d'une
certaine rancoeur je veux dire c'est le
printemps des groupuscules
d'extrême droite par est il enfin au
lieu de les stigmatiser il serait
peut-être temps de leur dire la vérité
on sait bien que eva braun c'était pour
la galerie
si le mariage gay existait en 40 adolphe
et rudolf serait sans doute les grand
père comblé d'un petit galliano
on n'en parle pas l'air de frigide
barjot insulter c'est vrai que qu'est ce
qui s'est passé qu'est ce qui s'est
passé est là couché avec un beau chemin
c'est
c'est eh bah oui c'était très violent
c'est d'ailleurs moi je pensais qu'ils
allaient la tondre cela dit c'est une
comparaison un peu malheureuse enfin si
à la libération tous les collabos
s'était fait honte par des games aurait
sans doute eu un peu plus de style
je me disais j'ai une question facile à
droite revient au pouvoir avec elle
abroge la loi les couples qui seront
passés entre les gouttes et qui aura
adopté les gamins ce qu'on considérait
comme des collectors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va les retrouver sur ebay va en
gamins d'occasion près abolition mariage
gay sens esthétique prémâché oedipe à
l'état neuf
notre truc c'est que ma copine veut
adopter en ce moment et moi j'ai dit oui
à condition que l'enfant viennent d'un
couple gay c'est beau c'est beaucoup
plus simple je veux dire aux gamins je
pourrai toujours lui dire si tu savais
d'où tu venais tu la fermes mais un peu
mais faites moi ce qui me gêne avec
cette loi c'est qu'elle n'ouvre pas de
nouveaux droits aux hétérosexuels bah
oui c'est moi aussi comme les couples
homos je veux accéder à une sexualité où
on n'a pas besoin de se préoccuper de la
contraception puisque les homos peuvent
avoir des gosses sans faire l'amour je
revendique le droit de ne pas en avoir
en le faisant
[Applaudissements]
égalité égalité
pour dire la vérité moi je trouve ces
manifs assez belle quoi pour une fois
que les gens manifestent pas pour des
questions de fric ça serait quand même
tu vois pas la droite manifeste pour des
acquis métaphysique la gauche pour des
acquis matériels chacun se bat pour ce
qui lui manque
toute façon cette histoire faut être
clair un enfant n'a pas besoin d'un papa
et d'une maman non il a besoin de deux
adultes
donc deux papas
[Applaudissements]
international attentat contre
l'ambassade de france en libye alors il
commence à s'internationaliser les
corsages le bien c'est s'en prendre à la
résidence d'été de bhl
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
boston alors on a retrouvé les auteurs
c'est joe carnahan f l'inventeur du
triathlon moderne on commence par un
marathon on continue par une traque en
voiture on termine dans un bateau
dans le type il a terminé dans un sale
état il cligne des yeux pour donner ces
réponses tellement il est abîmée après
le scaphandre et le papillon l'intuber
le kebab
alors il paraît que c'est la faute de
son frère le frère s'est radicalisé au
daguestan enfin tu m'étonnes rien que le
nom du pays tu sais qui va pas revenir
avec des cheveux longs et les lunettes à
la john lennon
football le bayern écrase le barça
dortmund écrase le real la finale aura
lieu à wembley pour une fois que les
allemands vont atterrir en angleterre
cercle et les allemands moins de chômage
plus de croissance
mais ce qu'on peut vraiment admiré un
peuple qui idolâtrent franck ribéry
[Rires]
culture un tribunal a décidé que les
participants de l'île de la tentation ne
seront pas des artistes interprètes ah
bon donc les conneries qu'il raconte
c'est vraiment eu
tout le génie des participants de la
télé-réalité engager des frais d'avocats
pour faire reconnaître par un tribunal
qui sont fondamentalement débile
justice le syndicat de la magistrature à
un mur des cons
ça c'est un peu le facebook à la
française tout ça alors sur ce mur sont
affichées des photos de personnalités
essentiellement de droite bon le
syndicat s'est défendu en disant les
blagues d un langage pas les décisions
des autres c'est vrai en dehors des murs
du tribunal les juges de nuremberg
étaient très connus pour leur humour
antisémite
bonne nouvelle non plutôt un message
santé dans le vaucluse est un père de
famille qui a coupé le sexe de son
enfant
voire au circoncire il faut choisir
alors pas belle la vie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux